tyler tony and his dude perfect co-stars
are known for creative trick shots and
absurd dares but did you know tony has
also saved rhinos and shattered world
records keep watching to learn more
about youtube's favorite bearded
renaissance man the dude perfect team
spends a lot of their time competing
against each other in what they call
battles which are based on the original
competitions that spawned the channel
these can be anything from demolition
derby to a giant version of pictionary
according to the official dude perfect
wiki tony has the most battle wins out
of the entire dude perfect ensemble cast
with 26 solo battle wins he currently
has a 12 win lead on any of his other
castmates the battle videos are some of
the highest viewed videos on their main
youtube channel with their most recent
airsoft battle video amassing over 12
million views in under 4 months in
addition to the sports based
competitions tony has also performed
well in the dude perfect overtime
segments will unfortunate and cool not
cool first and foremost tony is an avid
hunter and fisherman there are pictures
of him all over his instagram with fish
ducks turkeys geese and larger game from
reading some of the descriptions on
these posts it appears as though he does
his due diligence as far as getting
permits sticking to quotas and generally
respecting the local wildlife he also
seems to work hard at passing down these
practices to his children in a
responsible way in addition to hunting
tony participates in animal conservation
efforts as well as recently as may of
2021 he traveled with the dude perfect
crew to south africa and participated in
some rhino rescue with the rhino 9-1-1
organization in total they helped
tranquilize five animals so that
veterinarians could get close enough to
treat them for injuries sustained from
illegal poachers it seems that some of
these efforts may be having a positive
effect as some species of rhino in south
africa are rising in numbers and getting
closer to being taken off of the
critically endangered list according to
the world wildlife fund social media has
been picking apart the dude perfect
videos for years accusing them of using
cgi and other tricks in order to fake
their shots it got so heated at one
point that the group did an interview on
the today show to address the
controversy and they emphatically
repeated that they do not fake their
trick shots in any way obviously that
won't stop people from leveling
criticism at the group but tony doesn't
seem very bothered by this in fact when
people first started questioning the
veracity of their videos he took the
criticism in stride if people are
thinking that there's no way it could
actually be done in real life then we're
obviously doing something right after
such a wide array of success it's hard
to say exactly how much tony is worth
he's been collaborating for years with
his four other youtube partners which
means that his net worth is
intrinsically tied in with theirs even
when trying to guess how much the group
as a whole is worth the numbers can vary
according to celebrity net worth tony
could be worth around 10 million dollars
assuming the channel's net worth is
evenly split among the cast members
other websites such as wealthy gorilla
suggest a more conservative group net
worth of 30 million dollars but that's
nothing to sneeze at the dude perfect
group aren't just wasting their money on
frivolous purchases either all five cast
members are pretty charitable with tony
being far from the exception in addition
to flying to south africa to help
endangered species he's joined his
professional partners in donating to
organizations like charity water
compassion international and even the
make-a-wish foundation from charity to
trick shots it's no secret that the dude
perfect guys love taking their
challenges to the next level especially
when world records are involved
currently tony reigns supreme as a
four-time guinness world record holder
just on his own not even counting the
group awards that they have all earned
collectively his first award was won on
january 23 2017 when tony threw a
football into a basketball hoop from 50
yards away he added a second world
record to his resume the very next day
after successfully throwing another
football through a hoop from over 99
feet in the air the following year tony
set a particularly slimy world record
when he crushed 45 eggs with his toes in
30 seconds in 2019 he won himself
another award plaque for successfully
slicing 66 lemons and limes in 30
seconds for one of their overtime
segments as of spring 2022 none of these
records have been surpassed by any
challengers and it should be interesting
to see what sorts of records he and his
buddies try to set in the future
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]